all right today's movie retrospective
we're actually this was one of the first
movies I wrote down when we started
doing a list when we first started
thinking about doing movie reviews so
I've been wanting to do this almost from
the beginning of when we started this
series and this is the 1978 quasi
vampire film Martin directed by George a
Romero who obviously this is actually
kind of one of his lesser-known movies
obviously you know very he's best known
for all his you know zombie saga so I
kind of feel like a lot of his other
movies sort of go under the radar a lot
more just because his zombie movies are
so iconic and so popular and so
influential but he actually did make I
think his zombie movies for only about
half of his movie output over the years
so he actually did make things in about
a lot of other types of you know in a
lot of other kind of horror things in
the genre he made the crazies in I think
he came on 1973 which kind of priests
aged the whole 28 days later rage virus
zombies everything it's not really a
zombie movie but it's about you know a
disease outbreak that makes everybody
Ray J or whatever now Martin came out in
1978 and it was kind of Romero's take on
the vampire genre but in much the same
way as his zombie films were kind of
like a modern updating of the original
zombie legend the ghoul legend Martin is
kind of his updating of the vampire
mythos and he's almost kind of playing
with the idea of the realism of
vampirism versus the mythology of
vampirism it's so I've actually seen
this movie called like a vampire version
of taxi driver which I think that's kind
of accurate I guess so yeah yeah I've
never seen this before last night was
the first time I had seen the movie it's
a really interesting kind of movie and
the thing about it is that one of the
things I love about this movie and I
think contributes a lot to kind of the
overarching feel of it I'm gonna say
this is not it's a horror movie but it's
only nominally a horror movie it's
almost kind of like a gritty 70s drama
with like vampire elements I almost
wanted
it's kind of if you guys have seen like
Abel Ferrara's driller pillar it kind of
reminds me of that sort of thing where
it's like the whole thing is set in this
really decaying suburb of Pittsburgh
like outside of Pittsburgh everything is
just brown and grotty and gross and
depressed
it looks like Detroit and that really
contributes a lot to kind of the you
know like all the decor is like so 70s
it's pretty tough it's pretty
interesting to see if you're old enough
to remember those kind of times I mean
years you're seeing 60s cars and
seventies cars and how crappy paint was
back then and how quickly a car would
fall apart you know it's like 77 or 78
when would you say it was 78 when this
is fun yeah it was filmed in 77 77 yeah
and you can see that some of these cars
are late 60s and are already falling
apart there so yeah you know only a few
years later the cars were decay so
nothing was really built well back then
and you look at the interior design of
the sets you know it was pretty mundane
pretty bad weren't even sets I mean yeah
there were people's houses yeah I mean
the main set at the house which was
tanta Cudas house was actually the I
think it was the sound guys grandmother
yeah so that was her actual house they
didn't do any for lease yeah that kind
of see it's a different feel to it
because a lot of times movies from the
70s are filmed and really kind of
special locations or opulent locations
which that doesn't really give the view
or the modern view or the real feel of
the way the seventies were I can
remember the way the SEM he's actually
looked in most places didn't look that
good yeah dirty and nasty hello
most of the United States kind of look
like a developing third-world country by
today's standards so it was very select
I said this movie it's kind of like a
drama with like as I said horror
elements now don't go into it expecting
like a fun movie this is kind of a
bummer it's kind of a downer it's more
of a character study than any of his
other movies it kind of concerns and
this is kind of an interesting thing
about how this movie starts the opening
sequence of this movie establishes right
away the main character of Martin is
essentially a serial killer yeah I mean
he's stalking a woman on a train he
basically drugs her opens up her wrists
with a razor blade and drink
for blood yeah but then after this
opening sequence in which we see like so
much is kind of said in the open it like
set up in the opening sequence because
Martin sees things as though he is like
the classic movie vampire yeah this dude
thinks he's a vampire yes is serial
killer when he sees things when you see
things from his perspective yeah
everything is very it's in black and
white it's very romanticized it looks
like you know like an old vampire movie
with these buxom ladies and their old
white dress and they're calling to him
and then there's all these villagers
with torches like trying to get him and
he looks all suave with his like
unbuttoned what he looks all like
watering Heights and [ __ ] so that's how
he sees things going on but this great
opening sequence not only did establish
like I said that he's a serial killer
it's kinda it's a nasty sequence because
it's filmed so realistically it's not
quick edited it's not anything like that
it goes down in this little bitty you
know sleeper car in a train but so he
breaks into this woman's sleeper car on
this train and he has an idea in his
head he sees in black and white he sees
the woman in this dress and she's got
her arms outstretched to him and
everything like that and then they cut
back to the reality where she's in the
bathroom you hear the toilet flush it's
like you know she comes out of the
bathroom she's like blowing her nose and
she's got like what do you call Beauty
mask [ __ ] all over face and everything
like that so it's like she doesn't look
romantic in the least it's like she
looks like she's ready for bed she's got
a big fluffy bathrobe on and [ __ ] and
then they have like this big struggle
now the interesting thing about this
though is that after this very long
opening sequence where it's established
that he is a killer that he drinks
people's blood he drugs women it's
implied that he raped them I don't
really know if he does it's not really
made Sodom think so because later on
yeah there are some things he says that
it could go either way you know so then
he kind of makes it looks like a suicide
and leaves and then you kind of get this
mysterious sequence where he gets picked
up at the train station by this creepy
old dude like in a white suit and at
first you're not really sure what the
relationship between these two is he's
just kind of like come on to the house
and like you know this kids just like
following behind this
but then as the movie goes on the great
trick that Romero pulls is that he gets
you to sympathize with Martin even
though from the jump the very beginning
of the movie he shows Martin doing these
horrible horrible things and yet he's
still a sympathetic character at conduct
I know what I mean and I think it's
because because the whole the central
conceit of the movie is that you are not
sure he thinks he's a vampire
yeah the old guy in the white suit who
you later find out is his much older
cousin Santa CUDA who he has come to
stay with presumably after the other
members of his family have died or
whatever I think they kind of imply that
later on but he's kind of the last of
the line to look after this kid now Tata
CUDA is very old-school he's Lithuanian
actually very religious and he also
believes that Martin is a vampire but in
the old-school garlic and crosses kind
of way yeah this guy here he's related
to Martin yeah there you find anything
you find out that there's been vampirism
in the family but you also find out
there's insanity in the family and this
cousin his basically it's kind of like
the the van Helsing of the family
keeping track of who the vampires are so
there's a reason why Martin thinks he's
a vampire and you know really I was
watching it I was wondering whether or
not he really was a vampire that's on
how you define vampire you know he
wasn't the undead but he didn't claim to
be yeah and it was never really claimed
anywhere in the movie that they believed
that the vampires were Undead they just
thought vampires were people that kill
people and drink their blood which
that's what Martin was doing and another
thing that's weird about the movie you
said them the movie is kind of shot if
you ask me it's shot almost like in a
home-made way it's written pretty well
you can tell that the movie was
originally a lot longer and edited down
impt into this the initial cut was 2
hours and 45 minutes yeah and it's still
a little long by today's standards but
it is it is an interesting watch it's
not a modern movie but it is a pretty
good movie it's got a lot of good ideas
in it it was I would say the movie was
probably ahead of its time I could
understand why it's kind of a cult movie
I was watching it and it was really
reminded me of a serial killer that was
a
about that time I might have been there
early 80s I think his name was chase
some of my mother chased he was known as
the vampire killer who was running
around killing people drinking their
blood it's a lot like that that was a
real-life case I can't kid do you think
of that guy's name off the top I know I
think I know you telling this last name
chase out in California so I'm watching
the movie I'm going yeah there was a guy
who was actually like this yeah and it
made me wonder if that guy was
influenced by this movie or not maybe I
think you know of course this off the
top of my head I think the chase case
happened after this movie so I would
imagine he probably saw this movie it
could be I mean it could very well be
I'm just doing a lot of stuff that
serial killers are the 70s did stalking
people and getting into their houses and
busting in on women and having weird
relationships with women that weren't
you know it's it's interesting from that
point of view I really liked the
soundtrack the music I thought I really
have to call out the score you're very
very cool it's like it kind of it kind
of wavers between kind of like an old
gothic like piano type of thing and what
kind of a free jazz yes kind of thing
and it really works I should point out
where we're talking about the score if
you've ever seen which I have not and I
don't know if I'd want to see it but the
Italian cut of this movie which is
called when pair actually has a score by
Goblin obviously most famous for doing
most of Dario Argento's movies and
they're kind of a prog rock band so I
don't really know I don't think it would
work maybe it does if any of you have
seen it like let me know in the comments
but I I don't know if I want to watch it
because I really like the score of this
so much and it really fits in with this
whole bleak sort of atmosphere that this
movie
spaghetti atmosphere we got a storm
going on outside so you might hear
something if anybody hears this it's
just vampire atmosphere yeah we didn't
add that that's that's actual Florida
atmosphere is like storming outside so
yeah but that was another thing I wanted
to say too is that there's another
interesting thing too is that George
Romero does and actually George Romero
is in this in a cameo
Tom Savini and Tom Savini this is
actually the first time that Tom Savini
had done effects for a George Romero
movie yeah and you know and he's also in
this in a in a small role as he plays
the Cudas granddaughters boyfriend
Arthur and he's in a couple of scenes
but he also did all the effects for this
it's not a super super gory film mostly
most of the blood is kind of like you
know just slitting wrists and things of
that nature so it's not like the zombie
movies where heads get blown off or
anything but it's a you know kind of
like that can definitely tell this movie
was a series of movies that came from a
bunch of friends who were basically kind
of doing this on dance yeah
bandit style way you know on a very high
budget but they were talented yeah and
if you like tonight of the Living Dead
this is kind of a must-see movie it's a
I think anyone really who's in the
horror genre or you know maybe new to
the horror genre really should watch
something like this because this does
kind of take it back to the roots and it
does have just a really gritty kind of
realistic feel to it and I didn't we
weren't really watching a restored
version of it by today's standards it
was yeah I just had a DVD like the old
DVD I think it's Anchor Bay whatever
that came out yeah you can tell that
looks pretty aged you know the transfer
and that kind of adds to to it in a way
it looks like old crime-scene
photographs it looks like you know I
think we might have mentioned this on
another I don't remember what review was
but another one we were talking about
like old 70s movies and how that seems
like a really hard thing to be able to
to do in the modern eras to is to give
something that feel you know looking
like a snuff film
yeah that's something that you found
like some old videos like you found in
the bottom of a box and a garage
something you gotta get this feeling
that you're watching something you
really shouldn't be watching yeah that's
what that's that's thanks Zach it's
gonna get you dirty yeah yeah we're not
supposed to be seeing this you found it
somewhere what a ditch or something and
it's like yeah this definitely does have
that look to it except you know it's
looks like it was made by bad people
yeah but but then you know like in the
special features you know you hear Tom
Savini and everybody talking about
making the move and they're just like
regular or normal people made the book
well in Georgia
obviously he's passed away now but he
always seemed to me and and from what I
know from everyone that I've heard of
that has met him and things that he just
really seemed like a genuinely nice man
it's just a nice man who's very
down-to-earth with an ironic glasses
yeah and you know and he was I mean the
quintessential independent artist yeah
this movie was made for I've seen
figures between 80,000 and $250,000 um
it only got a limited release later on
not like his zombie movies which
actually did much better because this
this one like I said kind of under the
radar you can tell these were guys in
vans just with cheap cameras jumping out
making movies but they were well thought
out there well yeah oh you couldn't do
this today if you did this today you
could it would look a lot more - good it
would look too good and no one would
take interest in it they're like people
making cool movies and nobody even sees
them well how to do the place in the
time and also the location in a rotten
old place in Pittsburgh but you know it
looks like it's falling down you know
and mostly and that really like I said
adds to it kind of helps establish the
mood because what I was going to say
previously when I first mentioned George
Romero being in this movie was that he
is he has like a bit part as a young
priest and he comes over to town
sakuni's house because I guess he's just
cut moved to the parish or whatever and
so town Tokuda invites him over and so
George Romero is like this young priest
he's like hey more wine man I'm gonna
you know your food and all the sneeze
all yeah well I'm the cool priest and
you can tell that tanta CUDA is not
having it he's like you know the old
people don't like priests like you we
believe in demons and we do and then
there's kind of this awkward kind of and
the granddaughter's like talk to Kuno
can you please shut up it's like you're
really making everything awkward for
everybody so there's really this whole
thing about ancient beliefs versus
modernity and then there's an
interesting thing too about belief and
how beliefs influence reality because
here's the thing
Tata CUDA believes wholeheartedly that
Martin is not ferati yeah like in the
old-school sense of the word he brings
out the old family albums and he's like
this one's a vampire and that one's a
vampire and Martin's 84 years old even
though
looks like he's only about 19 or 20 yeah
cuz they never answered which was that
ever addressed because it's my me
watching it a lot of this stuff is
ambiguous
yeah and that was kind of doing they
know if he's really 84 or not now later
on Romero says he thinks that it's just
a delusion but he never really
definitively says I'm like I said Martin
is not a vampire
I got a gets depend on how do you define
a vampire well yeah and that's kind of
another thing to like I said when there
when we're talking about belief and
we're talking about perception about
vampires tanta CUDA has a particular
perception about what a vampire is so I
guess you watch the bill right Martin
also has a particular conception of what
a vampire is which he believes he fits
right but he doesn't believe in all the
old-school bit like he's like oh I can
walk around in the daytime I'm not
scared of garlic I'm not scared of
crosses but I drink blood and I'm 84
years old now it's debatable it's
possible that Martin could just be
mentally ill and I kind of leaned toward
that like all the stuff that he's seeing
with the romanticized vampire thing
that's just his delusion that's because
his other cousin doesn't believe that
he's 84 yeah that's not too good his
granddaughter who also lives there she
thinks the whole thing is [ __ ] she
thinks that I mean she feels bad and I
think maybe her feeling sympathy for
Martin helps the audience feel sympathy
for Martin not only because he seems
like such an innocent yeah but also
because she thinks that he's just a boy
there's mental problems who has been
warped by this family although in the
curse and I realize it makes him think
that he's a vampire and maybe it messed
him up although it's never really made
clear whether or not she definitively
has proof that he is not 84 I don't know
she doesn't but like I said because it
is ambiguous from the way I am that's
left ambiguous but like I said I saw it
I saw intimately it doesn't really
matter it because it doesn't matter that
she doesn't believe he's a vampire Roton
Tokuda believes he's a vampire and
Martin believes he's a vampire they
believe two different things about
vampirism but they both believe there
and so reality stems from their belief
like the things that happen stem from
their different differing beliefs now
because
steena who is the granddaughter she is
not privy I mean she doesn't know I
don't think she knows that Martin is a
serial killer obviously but all she
knows is that her whole life she's heard
the old people in the family from the
old country back in Lithuania talking
about oh there's three vampires still in
the family and we have to destroy them
and all this other kind of stuff because
I mean that's the whole point of the
movie and that's kind of there's a lot
of black humor in this as well because I
really I mean the funny part of this is
that really as soon as you see the whole
opening sequence on the train and then
tanto Cunha brings Martin to the house
and pretty much says I'm gonna save your
souls and I'm gonna kill you right you
know what I mean so it's kind of like
you know it's kind of funny because
you're like wow this old dudes crazy but
Martin is crazy too yeah so in a way
it's kind of like a sad movie right and
I want to talk to a little bit about the
relationship that he has with mrs.
Santini the soon as Martin comes into
town you know kuda has like a butcher
shop or a grocery store or whatever and
he gives Martin a job like going around
making deliveries and he meets this kind
of 70s stereotype of the lonely bored
housewife who's just looking to get some
but they kind of established this kind
of thing so I've been reading some stuff
about this and somebody made the
interesting point that had mrs. Santini
and Martin actually developed a normal
sexual relationship which they seemed
kind of moving in that direction sort of
even though they were both very damaged
that maybe he would have gotten out of
his delusion if indeed it was a delusion
you know what I'm saying like because
because his whole thing was that maybe
his vampiric tendency is kind of it
seemed like it was implied that it
stemmed from like sexual inadequacy like
because he was like well they have to be
asleep or you know I have to get blood
from them and then after he started
having this relationship with mrs.
Santini he started having a hard time
like picking victims that he couldn't
like detach himself from his victims
anymore so there is kind of that
implication to that that was it was a
psychological issue that was manifesting
itself through the lens of his families
you know superstitious right is I think
what it was like I said it's left
ambiguous he could have been a vampire
you know or he was just a serial killer
he was mentally ill or whatever but I
have to say too after you give props to
John amplest he plays Martin in this
this was actually his first movie role
primeira saw him like on stage like in
some school players I'm sure like that
and thought that's him and he put him in
the movie and he carries the whole movie
he's just he's so sympathetic and yet
also kind of otherworldly and weird but
you know you kind of see everything
through his eyes to me it kind of looks
like an evil and demented Mark Hamill he
does kind of look a little bit like that
I wouldn't say evil and Amanda just kind
of a dementia care reminds me Mark
Hamill yes she does and I was gonna say
I didn't know I couldn't remember if
John amplest had actually been in any
other movies but he was he was actually
in a bunch of George Romero's other
movies he was actually in if you guys
saw Creepshow which i want to do a show
on eventually he was the dad in father's
day that crawled out of the grave I want
my cake you know but you couldn't tell
him was him because he had so much you
know skeleton or whatever but that was
him and he had a couple other bit parts
in most of his zombie movies and [ __ ]
later on I think he teaches Performing
Arts in Pittsburgh now but you know he
was really great in this movie
everybody's really good in this movie
and it's you know one that doesn't get
seen a lot and if you kind of like the
vampire as disease type of thing which
you kind of saw in the hunger and maybe
like the addiction and some kind of
later movies like that this seems like
it was probably kind of where some of
that came to I can recommend it if you
like if you like Night of the Living
Dead if you like vampire movies like 77
days kind of slow burn yeah I could
recommend it it is it does have some
slow parts by today's standards but you
know they just they edited movies at a
different pace back then the priorities
were low because everyone didn't have a
DD you didn't have a DD nowadays they
condense this movie into probably about
a half hour and it would still be a
watchable movie not quite as fast paced
as not a living dead yet still good real
good I could recommend it interestingly
he wanted to shoot this entire movie in
black and white also yeah but the
producer said yeah I don't think it
would have been so so he only did the
fantasy versions like when you see
things from Martin's interview it's done
in black and white no I think that
creepy shitty nineteen seventies color
really really did how works for this
movie yeah and you know like I said it's
I you know I didn't even mention the
thing about that we
with that weird soundtrack just kind of
demented music and it's not demented on
purpose is just that's just the way but
and this kind of makes you feel detached
from it it's weird yeah yeah but yeah I
really like to movie so you know like I
said if you if you like that kind of
slow burn 70 sort of thing and if you
haven't seen if you like Romero's other
movies it's kind of a similar in theme
and similar in tone to some of this
other ones but this is kind of his
modernist skeptical take on the vampire
legend so if you haven't seen it you
should probably check it out and
remember if you like the show to like
share subscribe on all your social media
and share with all your friends if you'd
like to financially support the show you
can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast WordPress com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account where you can give a
one-time donation if you'd like to and
remember to check out our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and our movie reviews which come out
every Friday and until next time bye